Pat I love your mom loved cuz she's dead
cuz I'm kind of the me an office
prankster second of course to Roberta
who's Roberta your mom your mom Roberta
my mother's name was Kristi Howard Clark
was it Kristi Howard Clark that need of
death so you didn't really know this
woman at all either no but like what is
knowing now it is okay who are they who
are you we're living we just wanted to
see the goddamn Hollywood sign and
you've ruined our last day in America
you're not gonna throw out our years of
pen pal I'm back and forth over one
crazy day I wrote you for two years
after middle school you were writing
with my little brother
hi Dave day it's the vie for ten years I
was writing your little brother okay
that that can't be tried told him I
loved him
that doesn't make me it does I had you
for two years and the sleeve I can't
believe mom worked with such idiots but
you made us promise me to show you this
video if she ever prematurely passed
away hello everyone it's me Christy the
main office prankster thank you for all
the wonderful years at telamericorp I
cherished him not cherish you Jillian
you were always there to listen I don't
think we ever spoke Montez thank you for
letting me borrow your Wayne's World DVD
sha ween and Bill I had the baby she's
in Phoenix Phoenix and finally Anders
Blake and Alan and the other office
pranksters I wanted to show you a
painting I made for your cubicle I'm so
proud of it and I hope that it brightens
your day she was a painter mm-hmm
it's right over here
so I'm the main office bring stir for
life your mother it doesn't affect me
I've seen a lot of porn of this doesn't
know yeah I still got it
you